What are some of the properties of simulated amealing? No we
already talked about two of them: this idea that as the temperature
goes to zero, it acts, it's acting more and more like
hill climbing, only taking steps that improve the fitness. And as T
goes to infinity, it's like a random walk around the neighborhood.
So you, wherever point where it is, it's willing to go to
any of the other points in the neighborhood and it just
doesn't, it doesn't really pay any attention to the fitness function anymore.
>> So huh,
so that makes sense right if I wanted to, to go
with the analogy. High temperatures like a lot of heat, which
is a lot of energy and so molecules bounce around a
lot. That kind of has the effect of flattening out the fitness
function. T goes to zero, that's no energy. It's like you've
frozen; molecules can't move and so you only move to places with
lower energy or in this case, higher fitness. So that all
makes sense. So how do I get from one to the other?
You see you had any
>> You had in the algorithm decrease t, but do we need
to decrease t quickly, slowly, what's the right way to do it?
>> So in practice, we wanted to decrease the temperature slowly, because
it gives it, the system a kind of a chance to explore at
the current temperature before we start to cool it out. So, well,
one way to think about it is, if you think, if you consider
some kind of function that we're trying to optimize,
when the temperature is high, it kind of doesn't
notice big valleys. It's, it's willing to kind of
wander through big valleys. As the temperature gets cooler, the
valleys become boundaries and it starts to break things
up into different basins of attraction, but smaller gullies
it still is able to walk, walk over. As
the temperature gets even lower, those become barriers as well.
And so what we really want to do is give
it a chance to kind of wander to where the,
the high value points are before cooling it so much
that it can't now bridge the gulf between different local optimums.
>> Ok, that makes sense. So, property
as it's sort of bouncing between exploration and
exploitation. I buy that. So where do you end up? Where do you end up?
>> Well, if we're lucky, we end up at the global optimum; yay.
>> [LAUGH] Is there anything, you know, we could say
that we could characterize how often we end up there, or are we
going to have to do randomized restarts
and do simulated annealing a million times?
>> So, we're not going to be able to go through the argument for exactly
why this is true, but there is a
remarkable fact about simulated annealing that is worth
mentioning. That the probability end at any, any given point x in the space is
actually e to the fitness of x divided
by the temperature and then normalized, because this
is a probability distribution over the input space. So this is,
this is pretty remarkable right? So this is saying that it's most
likely to be in the places that have high fitness, right?
because that's those are where it's going to have the highest probability of
being. And you can see now what the relationship with the
temperature is here too, that as we bring the temperature down, this
is going to act more like a max. It's going to put
all the probability mass on the actual x star, the, the, the
optimum. And as the temperature is, is higher, it's going to smooth
things out and it'll, you know, be randomly all over the place.
>> Hm.
>> So, so that's why it's really important
that we eventually get down to a very low
temperature. But if we, again, if we get there
too quickly, then it can, it can be stuck.
>> Hm.
>> Right, because it's spending again, time proportional to the fitness.
So, it is spending time ending up at points that are not
the optimum, if they're say, close to the optimum.
>> Okay, so you know, I actually now that you, you spell that out,
I actually recognize this distribution, it has
a name it's called the Boltzmann distribution.
>> That's exactly right, and if there's people listening that
have a physics background, they're going to probably be poking
their eyes out because, huh, it's the case that we,
we're using a number of physics concepts, but we don't quite
use the same notation and we don't quite do things exactly the
way that a physicist would. So,
there's definitely a relationship and the Boltzmann
distribution is used quite a bit in, in the physics community, but
it may not be exactly like that so don't, try not to panic.
>> Yeah, it's more like an analogy, like
so much of life. It's a simulated Boltzmann Distribution.
>> It's like a simile.
>> [LAUGH]